war huh what is it good for well it's
good for some gameplay of Warhammer 40k
Dawn of War 3 and we've got 60 minutes
here from the Space Marine campaign
leave a comment below telling us what
you think of dawn of war 3 and don't
forget to subscribe to GameSpot for all
the ladies and gaming videos and news
[Music]
yet by order of the Imperial commander
Inquisitor home reinforcements were kept
in high a little bit and forbidden from
landing upon the planet
even the Knights of house lock on their
own to defend against the rampage
help alive when the Blood Ravens
descended from the sky
chapter master Gabriel and Charles
defied the inquisitors blockade that
came to the aid of house Farnum
rise we are forced to hell
for there
the Inquisitor personal please
this is gabriel angeles chapter master
of the blood ravens my space marines and
i of deployed to the bridge
we shall stem the tide
[Music]
kill every orc that crosses this
threshold blood Ravens
[Music]
the orcs are trying to flank
[Music]
that should stem the tide for now
lady Solaria my brothers have the breach
contained I'm moving on where am i
needed understood I'm on my way I need
to find another way up Space Marines
scout marines employing blank grenade
with papers
with me scout Marines we serve the
chapter chapter master to battle barks
dauntless I require a tactical marine
squad drop to my position
ready
understood
[Music]
talking
[Music]
on my way
protect the array
Oh enemy kill gotta target as commanding
read relocating hey def double dagger
uuh to face Cal Marine snipers deployed
we can kill that all heavy weapon team
from a distance we've scouted a small
enemy targeting orcs
[Applause]
Solaria the array is secure dauntless do
you read r1 forces deployed to that
hangar in advance of my arrival
I'm
no war pots broke through I must hurry
we support inquire from here affirm
chapter master understood walk trucks
they new threat from down there
surprise crudely effective all their
savagery the orcs are resourceful
you'll die one by one
[Music]
thoughtless I've reached the hangar
underfoot an assault reported on standby
awaiting your deployment order
[Music]
chapter laughter the entrance to keep
stands read under attack I'll be there
soon lady Solaria
tactical Marines ready rifle Scouts
deployed
Marines deployed
Marines deployed the emperor lights our
way
how's far LACMA yet enjoy
something out
[Music]
tell the Jimmy so we can learn - stumpy
nights no pillage for you only
[Music]
these orcs will be taught to fear our
colors summon our sacred standard and
rally beneath it brothers
we all have been coming out we've been
fighting them without reprieve you
fought valiantly enduring this your call
for aid should not have gone unanswered
[Music]